well
[Music]
good day sal y jaramillo greets you with
the most outstanding headlines of the day
two people died in an
accident believed to have been caused by
recklessness near
hollywood and sahara streets police report
that a group of cars were participating in
clandestine races  When the
mishap happened it is believed that one of the
passengers was partially out of
the window when the car that was going at a
high speed in motion passed a
woman on a bicycle causing her to fall
while the passenger was also
ejected from the adam and died when  same
as the cyclist the police are looking for the
driver any information
please call the authorities the
food bank true and square has teamed up with
the city of henderson to
hold a series of
food distributions at five different sites this
week the sites  They will be different
primaries and the first started today at
Tyler Elementary School from 8 to 11 in the morning,
the second  This week's distribution
will be in the elementary school, and you see, two other
events are
planned for Thursday. The service
is available to all the public who
are in need and can go by
car to pick up the food to go and
little by little the city of  las vegas is
reopening more of its attractions this
week several shows are anticipated to return
to the hotel zone
including is absent which reopens its
curtains at the sensor powers on
wednesday and the comedy peep takes on
traghen at the flamengo on thursday both
shows have  security protocols are in place in order
to reduce the
possibility of contagion by the
coronavirus on the part of the investor, it was
announced that seven of its biggest
shows will return for the first
week of November and the expectation has
also been accumulating before the
opening of the new hotel and casino  close
in downtown las vegas since
a new tourist attraction hasn't opened
downtown in 40 years the owner  The city
opens to the public on Wednesday indicated
in Spanish, it will be covering the event on
our digital platforms and
social networks.  of
wind will continue until 9 at
night have a good day I am salt and
jaramillo and this was stated in
Spanish
[Music]